étranger
[Musique]
48 de nos familles bénéficient actuellement de
repas scolaires gratuits dans une ville comme Londres, l'une
des villes les plus prospères au
monde, c'est choquant de
penser que ce nombre d'enfants et
nos familles ont du mal à joindre les deux
bouts et  ont du mal
à fournir la nourriture dont ils ont besoin
pour leurs familles, c'est vraiment une
statistique assez choquante.
Ainsi, lorsque nous parlons
de la faim, nous parlons d'
enfants qui viennent à l'école et comptent sur
un repas chaud et nutritif à l'heure du déjeuner et
c'est pourquoi nous menons une campagne pour
étendre l'éligibilité afin que davantage de familles
vivant dans la pauvreté puissent accéder à une bonne
nutrition à l'heure du déjeuner.
Musique]
c'est déconcertant et je pense que nous devons
décider en tant que nation
si nous apprécions la santé des enfants et
si nous pensons qu'il est juste
que les enfants ne reçoivent pas la
nutrition dont ils ont besoin pour accéder à l'apprentissage
pour accéder à la même expérience de leurs
pairs
[Musique  ]